if Matthew Ronaldo in the same football
team in any football team chances are
they're going to win who do you think's
the best of all time of the player
they're trying to get this out of me I
like you do you try you're not you're
trying
hi I'm Gary Cahill and this is my fives
on sport Bible
right okay
um so I'll go for the goalkeeper as
Peter check
for me
of course I was up there but I think
when I first got to the club Peter check
was there had some good memories
fantastic goalkeeper I think with Petey
was um really good talker really good
organizer I am good with his feet good
distribution I think for me was like an
all-round
goalkeeper but like I say chords for it
was kinda the next in line and equally
as good so it was a tough one but I
think between the both we had one and
two at the time which was probably one
of the best in the league I think
I'll probably go with
I mean that's really quick as a
no-brainer but I think I will put in
David Louise
for a number of reasons for the fact
that he is probably one of the best on
the ball center backs I've played with
they can pick a pass from anywhere his
ability to step out with a ball
and his character he was always a big
Joker so I think in a Fireside team be
good to have a character in there and
he's certainly that do you think he was
underrated
I think when you say under eight it does
look at his career and what he's done in
his career I don't see how he can be on
the raid I think sometimes people have
opinions on
obviously at the time he was kind of
quite a flare player for the center back
sometimes took chances sometimes got
away but sometimes didn't but
nevertheless he was his own personality
and he was a massive player like I said
when you look at his career for his
capture Brazil the trophy is one
obviously great members for me the
Champions League final playing with him
um I think his career speaks for itself
so
[Music]
Eden Hazard Ethan Hazard was unplayable
at times when I was at Chelsea he was he
was unbelievable so for me one of the
best players or the best player for
natural ability that I've played with
how was he on the training pitch very
casual yeah he was really a relaxed
personality wise very very relaxed and
didn't take anything too seriously never
felt like the pressure got to him ever
you remind me of a player that just
would go out and play with his mates in
the park if you know what I mean that
kind of play he wouldn't overthink the
matches he'd just get there be so
relaxed and then go out and just his
natural ability will take care of itself
and a lot of the time um especially in
the the
successful Seasons that we had with him
we'd look for him to change the game for
us you know it's kind of that play away
he's a sticky match and you kind of
wanting to get on the bus you know he's
going to change the game so big players
change games and he's definitely one of
them big players
Fabregas
almost like a quarterback he used to sit
in front of the back four for us when we
played Chelsea to give him the ball they
need to find passes very very clever
player a player that people said didn't
have a huge amount of pays he never
needed it he was so clever he brought
himself time on the ball
um the game looked very easy for him
very very good player big personality as
well big personality in the dressing
room which you always need in successful
teams
Didier Drogba
for obviously a legend at Chelsea
scored so many big goals won trophies
was this a big personality scored goals
that you should never score
[Music]
um very good I mean I had a great time
with Diego Costa as well I thought he
was brilliant for us
bought DDA when you think of Chelsea
when I first went to Chelsea you think
of the likes of
check Terry Lampard I see Carl Drogba
and these are the kind of iconic players
that was there at the time and yeah he
was he was a massive player that
Champions League final when it's him
stepping up to take that penalty did you
have any doubt at all
um no I didn't have a doubt because he
if you look over his career the amount
of big goals he scored
in big games he was almost he was like a
big game player when he come to life in
the big games and scored many important
goals for himself uh no and I was very
hopeful as well because I was even next
to other one after so I was really
hopeful that you scored so yeah I was
buzzing
[Music]
girl for Edison at Man City
I think he one is a top a top goal a
goalkeeper in terms of shot stopping but
it's one of the best goalies I've seen
or played against with his feet
I think he's almost like he's almost
like a midfielder in goal this passing
range is frightening the distribution's
frightening it's tough because he
started off a lot of attacks for them
and it sounds crazy but when you work on
facing them even you know when I was at
Chelsea or other teams you work on
facing them you work on how you're going
to press them
and it's very difficult to press when he
can pick
obviously your Easy Pass is here you can
pick the fall back out here you can pick
the full Buck out here it's got a
ridiculously long kick as everyone knows
so you can't even as a back four squeeze
up to the back to here because it'll
just the forward will be there and
you'll just reach him so there's so many
things to think about even from the
goalkeeper do you know what I mean so
hence why obviously Man City are as good
as the eyes is is one of the the reasons
for that and the way that he starts the
attacks off for them all the time
but
so Van Dyke for me again massive play
was uh early on his career I remember
playing he was at Southampton almost
learning his way there
got his move to Liverpool and uh yeah
the recipe for itself is obviously one
of the best center-backs in the world I
think and uh
seems a big character
um
quick strong regressive can play again
all the attributes that you need to be
uh a top player in European football
that's Premier League
so I'll go messy put him in the Midfield
played in the Champions League against
him when we was actually successful in
2012 which obviously the second leg was
a crazy game
but played against him then
um and yeah just phenomenal I don't
think he even needs a description on how
he plays that he just does look at the
name and that's it there's numbers the
way that the the amount of gold just
scored and everything is just
frightening just
himself and Ronaldo I think for me just
play on a different planet so yeah I'll
say him how did you think you got on
against him
I'd like to say we did all right because
it was uh I think the first leg was one
nearly we managed to keep him quiet
somehow and then again the second leg
there was so much drama involved in that
it was just our year but
um no we did it we did okay glad I'd
have to play against him every week
I'll go for Paul scholes I remember
playing my first I was obviously my
first Club was Aston Villa I got in the
first team there I only played 20 yard
games but one of them games before I
left
was against Man United and he scored I
don't know if you remember but a
screamer from outside the box I think it
was like a volley and that was my first
memories of him
while watching him before that obviously
when I was going through the Youth
System but one of the best midfielders
England's had
um the amount of titles and trophies man
you was incredible and like I said yeah
everyone knows Paul scholes is is
unbelievable
so I got Ronaldo just for what I said
with Messi and Ronaldo I think these
guys the numbers that they produce is
just mind-blowing really my games you
play my goals have scored again my
titles have won
um I speak for yourself two of the best
players in in World football who did you
find harder to come up against between
Ronaldo and Messi um I don't know to be
honest very different players again
Ronaldo had more of it he had more of a
presence in the Box he could score goals
with his head obviously outside both of
them might eat both of them on the pitch
had that kind of aura about him that
kind of respect whereas people were
coming shot him down and almost stopped
two yards away from him probably because
they didn't want to be made to look
stupid
um so they almost commanded that respect
from from the players people was kind of
a bit nervy around them because of what
they can do to you so two two big
presents on a football pitch
um so I can't choose between them who do
you thinks the best of all time of the
person they're trying to get this out of
me
you're trying uh I can't I can't choose
I can't choose he does the numbers are
just just incredible and obviously very
similar so it's very difficult to choose
I think who wins that match for other
side
I think
going against my teammates here but you
you can't even imagine Ronaldo in the
same football team in any football team
chances are they're going to win so I'm
going to go I want to go with these guys
and which team would you rather play for
I'd rather play yeah but I sleep by my
uh stick by my boys uh I'd rather play
this too
[Music]
[Applause]
anyone that you particularly had like
really tough days against
a check
no
Joe Hart
vanasar always scored against him